This is for cars?
Ugh.
He took the consultant's fees
and ran.
You know, I'm sure consultants
can get away with that.
I mean, it seems like a pretty
shady job to begin with.
Consulting?
Yeah.
I mean,
that's basically what I'm --
That's all I'm doing right now.
I'm a consultant.
I just take my friend Tall John
when I go get a car.
Yeah.
He acts
kind of intimidating.
[ Laughing ]
You think that's your negoti--
"How about we go
$300 off the price,
or my friend's
gonna beat you up?"
[ Both laugh ]
I would love it
if that worked.
It'd be like,
"Oh, yes, sir, Mr. Benson."
No, just some of those --
"I'll change
some of these numbers."
The guy I bought a car from wore
a cowboy hat and wore boots.
Why would you ever buy a car
from someone in cowboy hats
and a boot?
Why are you putting all
this shit out on the table?
I got to see it all.
I got to see what
we're talking about here.
Take it all in.
I think every one
of these things is confusing.
Anything that's stapled,
that's out.
I'm not dealing
with two pieces of paper.
Here's the two checks, so it's
proof she paid him twice.
They want $1,400 back.
$1,410.
Should I give it to them?
He was so convincing.
Everything he said, I was like,
"Ah, he's right."
[ Water bubbling ]
That guy, he showed up
with a goddamn manilla folder.
You can't buy
one of these, Doug.
You're buying
a 50-pack of these.
And you're not buying
a 50-pack of manilla folders
unless you're somebody
who does business.
God, it was good.